so right here in front of me I've got
every single iPad from Apple's current
iPad lineup we've got the 10.2 inch iPad
for 329 dollars we've got the iPad Mini
5 for $400 the iPad air three for five
hundred dollars and the two thousand
twenty iPad pro for eight hundred
dollars so in this video I'm gonna show
you guys all of the differences between
them and then give you my personal
recommendations on which iPad you should
be buying for your specific use case now
a lot of things have changed since I
made the last version of this video on
April 5th of last year especially the
introduction of iPad OS and most
importantly the addition of cursor
support only a couple of weeks ago
but before I get into that let's go
through all the physical differences
between these iPads the iPad pro is the
only one that's moved over to the new
modern design which includes square
edges compared to the other iPads
classic sham furred edges a display with
rounded corners compared to square
corners on the other iPads and even
bezels all around thanks to the face ID
authentication sensor compared to the
other iPads which have large bezels on
the top and bottom because they still
pack the classic touch ID home button
and on the back the pro looks quite a
bit different as well with a much larger
camera bump than the rest now in 2020
the iPad Mini is the only one that
doesn't get Apple smart connector which
is used to connect keyboard cases
without requiring batteries which makes
sense because it's so much smaller than
the rest the iPad pro is also the only
iPad that gets four speakers to on the
top and two on the bottom and this makes
a huge difference as you'll hear in the
sound comparison the pro is also the
only iPad that gets a USB C port making
it much more simple to transfer files
and connect devices transferring files
is still possible with the Lightning
port that comes on the rest of the iPads
but it's just not as convenient the pro
also comes with a faster 18 watt USB C
charger compared to 12 watts on the
others however it doesn't get a
headphone jack because Apple wanted to
make it thinner and yes it's crazy thin
compared to the rest but it can actually
Bend if you're not careful with it
unlike the other iPads moving on to
display differences the new air and many
have literally
identical displays but the mini packs
basically the same amount of pixels into
a smaller display so it has the highest
pixels per inch
out of the whole iPad lineup including
the pro and it also comfortably fits in
one hand so it's the lightest and most
portable out of all of these the iPad
pro has basically the same display as
the air but it's better in two ways
a higher 600 nits of brightness compared
to 500 in the addition of pro motion
technology
this basically means that it has a 120
Hertz refresh rate display but it also
has the added advantage of being able to
automatically adjust down to as low as
24 Hertz to match the content you're
viewing which helps save battery life
you can see the difference in fluidity
in this slow motion clip between the air
60 Hertz display and 120 Hertz on the
pro this also greatly reduces the lag on
the Apple pencil and proving the drawing
and note-taking experience thanks to the
120 Hertz display speaking of the Apple
pencil the pro is the only one that
supports this second version which is
quite a bit better because it
magnetically attaches to the side
instantly pairs and wirelessly charges
the other iPads only support the
original Apple pencil which you have to
plug into the Lightning port to charge
the new pencil 2 also has a new double
tap feature which is used to swap
between tools and various applications
back to the displays the budget 10.2
inch iPad is the only one that doesn't
get a very high quality display it's
still decent but it doesn't match the
rest first off it's not fully laminated
which basically means that unlike the
rest the display and the top cover glass
are two separate pieces this leads to it
looking a bit grey lacking deep blacks
like the rest and there's a gap between
the display and the glass which is
noticeable from an angle it's also the
only one that doesn't come with an
anti-reflective coating so you'll notice
reflections a lot more and it only packs
about 450 nits of brightness compared to
500 and 600 on the others
it also doesn't get p3 wide color gamut
like you get on the other eye pads which
makes for a very color accurate display
so as you can see the 10.2 inch iPad is
lacking in the display department now
let's get into compare
the speakers between these iPads
[Music]
[Music]
they all sound pretty decent but the pro
speakers are by far the best because you
get them on both the top and the bottom
which is great for gaming and watching
movies now before we get into
performance let's quickly compare the
cameras the pro gets a 12 megapixel wide
camera compared to an 8 megapixel wide
camera on the rest of the iPads so it's
gotta have a lot more detail it's also
the only one that comes with a 10
megapixel ultra-wide camera which gives
you a unique perspective that you can't
get on the other iPads it's also the
only one that can shoot 4k 60fps video
on either of the cameras compared to
only 1080p 30 video on the other eye
pads on the front side the budget iPad
only gets a 1.2 megapixel camera
compared to seven on the rest so selfies
will look quite a bit worse especially
compared to the iPad pro which also has
portrait mode thanks to the face ID
sensors the iPad pro also gets five
microphones instead of two on the other
eye pads so it sounds much better as
well this is the microphone quality on
the 10.2 inch iPad this is the
microphone quality on the iPad Mini this
is the microphone quality on the iPad
air this is the microphone quality on
the 2020 iPad pro and what's brand-new
this year is the lidar scanner which
greatly improves depth tracking for
things like augmented reality here it is
compared to the iPad air which doesn't
have lidar as you can see it's able to
detect objects and distance much more
accurately now let's finally get into
performance the pro gets twice as much
RAM compared to the other iPads so that
will help with productivity apps and
multitasking the air and mini share the
same 812 chip while the 10.2 inch iPad
gets a very outdated a10 ship from the
iPhone 7 and the pro gets the latest a
12 Z chip comparing multi-core
performance in Geekbench 5 the pro is
the clear leader with the budget iPad
being way behind the rest the air and
mini are basically identical because
they both use the same chip in the metal
test we see basically the same thing as
before with the pro having a massive
advantage in graphics performance and
here are the scores in an Tutu's 3d
benchmark so this shows a good rundown
on the performance differences between
these iPads now in terms of gaming the
iPad pro is by far the best choice
because it has a 120 Hertz display
allowing you to play it up to 120 fps
and games like fortnight the rest of the
iPads can only run games at 60 fps and
since the budget iPad isn't as powerful
fortnight actually limits it to 30 fps
out of all of them the iPad Mini is by
far the most comfortable to hold while
gaming but if you like to play using the
controller it shouldn't matter much now
let's quickly mention some other spec
differences before I start recommending
which iPad you should buy the budget
iPad gets Bluetooth 4.2 compared to 5.0
on the other iPads and the 20/20 iPad
pro is now the first iPad ever to
support Wi-Fi 6 another difference is
that the budget iPad only has the first
generation of touch ID compared to 2nd
gen on the iPad air and mini and asked
for battery life they're all rated for
the same 10 hours and one final
difference is the keyboard case support
all iPads except for the iPad Mini are
going to support the upcoming smart
connector keyboard cases with built in
track pads for the new cursor support
that works incredibly well and basically
helps make an iPad a pretty decent
laptop replacement the 10.2 inch iPad in
iPad air 3 get the Logitech combo touch
which is priced at 150 dollars but the
iPad pro actually gets the new magic
keyboard case which costs $300 but has a
number of advantages it features a USB C
port with pass-through charging meaning
that the main port is essentially freed
up for things like connecting storage
drives and other devices it's also the
first keyboard case that actually floats
the iPad and the air closer to you
making it more convenient touch while
also providing the same great magic key
switches that came with the 16 inch
macbook pro now with all of that said
and compared let's get into my
purchasing recommendations for which
ipad you should buy starting with who
should buy the 10.2 inch budget iPad and
why if you're buying an iPad for a child
you should probably go with the budget
iPad it's going to be good enough for
them to listen to music watch Netflix
and play basic games
chances are they
won't really mind the lower performance
or the worst quality display and if they
drop it and crack the screen it's
cheaper to replace since it's non
laminated and for adults it's by far the
cheapest way to get an iPad with a
trackpad keyboard case this is great for
someone who needs a cheaper laptop
replacement for doing things like
browsing the web using common apps like
QuickBooks and typing documents and
other business-related tasks now if
you're buying an iPad for a teenager
chances are they'll appreciate the extra
performance of the a12 chip and both the
iPad Mini and the iPad air as they'll
perform much better for gaming these
iPads are also great for those who
really care about display quality for
things like watching Netflix and
especially for those who want to use
their Apple pencil to draw with their
iPad I'd say the Mini is more for those
who would rather save $100 instead of
having the ability to use it with a
keyboard case and of course those who
don't mind the smaller display size now
the air is for people who want a premium
iPad that works as a laptop replacement
and has extra power to make sure all of
those apps work quickly and very
reliably especially while multitasking
the only limitation is the lightning
port which makes it difficult to connect
storage devices for file transfers and
that's where the iPad pro comes in with
its USB C port which is by far the best
case scenario for being a laptop
replacement the pro is for someone who
wants the absolute best iPad experience
you can get regardless of the price the
incredible performance the six gigs of
ram in the 120 Hertz display make it by
far the snappiest tablet out there
whether you're using it for gaming
drawing with the Apple pencil 2 or for
productivity work like video or photo
editing the pro is for those who are
initially considering an apple macbook
but would rather have the thin
lightweight and portable design of the
iPad pro instead it's got
top-of-the-line specs like Wi-Fi 6 it's
got the best cameras speakers and
microphones for those who care about
them and it's also the most future proof
by packing the new lidar scanner for
those who are interested in augmented
reality the choice you make really
depends on what you're going to be doing
with your iPad and in many cases paying
the extra price is worth it
because you don't want to be stuck with
a budget 10.2 inch iPad if you're trying
to play Fortnite competitively and on
the flip side you don't need to buy the
iPad pro if all you're going to be using
it for is watching Netflix and scrolling
through Facebook basically a good rule
of thumb is to choose the iPad you buy
wisely based on what you can expect to
do with it a year from today so
hopefully this video helps you make a
decision and if you've made up your mind
we'll have links to all of these iPads
down in the description below if you
enjoy this video tap like and click the
circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]